Comment ça, payer la recherche, bien t'utiliser
quand quelque chose est payé, tu le paies
avec de l'argent
[Musique]
maintenant tu sais que le président dit qu'il veut
construire un grand et beau mur, que le
Mexique le paie, je vais construire un
grand mur sur  notre frontière sud et je
demanderai au Mexique de payer pour ce mur et
nous lui ouvrirons un compte sur lequel le maître
peut mettre l'argent pour le payer. Je suis
sûr que le président ne ferait pas cette
promesse s'il ne disait pas la vérité.
les arrangements que nous avons au Mexique pour
payer cela, monsieur, c'est le secrétaire à la
Sécurité intérieure, ce qui me préoccupe,
c'est d'être en première ligne.
Savez-vous si nous avons des accords
avec le Mexique pour payer cela? Je sais que nous
avons des accords avec le Mexique pour  sécuriser
notre frontière avons-nous des arrangements avec
lui pour payer le mur comme le président
Trump a promis au peuple américain qu'ils le
feraient c'est une réponse facile oui ou non
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas ce que vous
entendez par arrangement nous avons beaucoup de
des accords avec eux pour accroître
la sécurité des commandes et payer pour un mur, ma
priorité est d'augmenter la sécurité des frontières
et de construire ce mur qui fonctionnera si
vous construisez un mur du côté américain de la
frontière, vous devez créer un no man's
land entre  le long fleuve Rio Grande,
combien d'acres de terres américaines
devons-nous céder au Mexique pour ce faire, ce que
nous devrons faire, c'est examiner le
terrain, la circulation, l'accessibilité
et vous avez raison, nous devons adapter les
solutions  pour chaque partie ou partie de la
frontière afin de m'assurer que nous n'ayons pas
à faire quoi que ce soit d'inutile. Je
ne vais pas vous faire écouter beaucoup de ses
discours de campagne sur un mur, un
très grand et beau mur qui s'étend sur toute la longueur de
notre sud.  frontière payée par le Mexique
J'ai entendu beaucoup de promesses au cours de mes
décennies ici, je vais voir celle-ci se
réaliser, merci m.  président pour les
prolongations
[Musique]